[Music]
i'm a big fan of articles where if you
read them as if they were happening in
the 1940s it would be completely
plausible
but if you read them now you'd go oh god
so we're going to act like this is 1940.
all right see let me know if my 1940s is
good yeah what is that like jazz are we
in the jazz listen here
like
i think we're like in world war ii i
think we're kind of world war ii in
world war two
i think that's 40 50's uh great gatsby
all right listen no that's that might be
20s 30s yeah roaring twenties yeah yeah
are you saying right now we could slap
slap our wives and it's fine okay
absolutely
i mean it's you shouldn't i just want to
be on the same imagination
let's be real it was very common during
that time okay only if they're being
frantic okay
because you grab them
get a hold of yourself sister
come on midge come on [ __ ] we have a
toothache we drink coca-cola with
cocaine in it yup oh true this is my
fort 1940s glasses pretty good okay
ready listen to this article and react
accordingly oh leave it to beavers is
that 40s no that's 50s i think
beaver i understand okay that's the
dad's glasses you know this justin a
professor at oklahoma christian
university who taught there for 40 years
was fired for bringing in a guest
speaker who was gay how dare he
i say
he brought in the son of satan
so what you're saying is
he brought someone who was happy because
in the 1940s gay was happy nice nice
that's actually like giggle time i like
son of satan better i like that one i
like that tape that was pretty good that
was hilarious they brought in a happy
human being at a respectable christian
establishment such as this yes wow was
it a church or school it was a school it
was a university um it was a graphic
design course for of you guys and this
teacher has been teaching there for 40
years brings in a guest speaker who was
gay it didn't even talk about gay [ __ ]
it just it just so happens that he was
gay that's gay and we're out of the the
time machine like we're in 2012 i'm out
of the time machine right now because
this is happening in 2022 this happening
now yeah what's the what's the uh uh
state for city
uh oklahoma
you know it makes it it makes it a
little more believable if you said that
happened in san francisco i'd be like
you're [ __ ] today right here in
oklahoma
that's a fine how do you do it
how'd they find out he was gay and then
how how did they fire the person because
obviously he went graphic design is
great
i don't know what he did
that'd be so funny if he's not even gay
and he's just flamboyant dude like he
came
who likes graphic design
and then they're like oh dear god they
brought a gay man into this christian
institution
and they're like i'm not gay
what if he wasn't even gay he was just
left-handed
and then it was like
oh this is in the other hand god damn it
you were so gay get this guy out
so weird though and we have a lot of
limp risk friends who are straight you
know what i mean like
i got some lymph wrist right yeah
we have friends that talk this way
[ __ ] italian
hey
wait is this a is it
is this a religious school yeah it's a
christian university but so then also in
addition to this the the guest speaker
who's gay he went to that school and
he's like an alumnus hello
that's so ridiculous oh that's just so
backwards too like uh
catholicism typically not always like we
have other branches but that's one of
the strict most strict
forms of christianity and the pope right
now is all for gay people
how are we not trickling down so the
pope is in the lead for this yeah the
pope probably signed this guy as a guest
what's the name of this school we need
to get the oklahoma christian universe
and a lot of the priests have a liking
to men and young boys so i don't know
like why they're so against it you know
that's the next favorite topic yeah dude
don't get me started on this dude dude
man isn't that crazy that that's like
now
that is weird funny
because okay so like it makes it makes
sense like if they brought in a gay
person to talk about gay like rights or
whatever they're like hey hey wait a
minute this is a christian institution
right but it's he's talking about
graphic design yeah and he just so
happens to be gay like that he's an
alumni yeah the alumni what the [ __ ] hey
i bet he still gets letters to this day
about donating to that [ __ ]
do you guys know what a
a junked professor is a junkie
like aj j u n c t johnson we all know in
like 30 seconds do what they're not
telling you in the story is this whole
presentation was just dicks
he's just showing you
this is how you shade and this is a
contrast color and this really
complements the testicles here's a
picture of lucifer's penis yeah yeah
yeah and then i'm like all right dude he
probably shouldn't be teaching there
yeah
so sometimes called contingent faculty
adjunct professors are part-time
professors they are not considered part
of the permanent just say
how [ __ ] soft we are no dude they're
so insulted to be called a substitute
teacher so that that gay teacher wasn't
a young professor at this school for 20
years as well like and they just got mad
he was a part-time professor for 20
years
the guest was a part-time professor
already and then the old professor got
fired for bringing in the part-time
professor that was already at that
school did they just find his only fans
or something like why why all of a
sudden like now he's gay yeah it's a
presentation of dicks it has to be it
had to be that's the only way and did
the adjunct professor get get fired as
well out no i mean he's not technically
um he doesn't have tenure so he didn't
he can't get let go he's just
so he's not always there wait the gay
the gay guy is uh a junk professor
that's what he was yeah he's he's been
at the same institution yeah for 20
years it says the openly gay speaker
doesn't make any sense was also an
oklahoma christian university alumnus
and was employed as an adjunct professor
at the university for nearly 20 years
what is going on so it's not like a
stranger that he brought in maybe a new
uh there's like a new dean of the school
a gay dude who loves adobe
this makes no [ __ ] sense how do we
get the schools back though how do we
help them how do we get the schools back
let's see well it's not like [ __ ]
rainbow drip out all their walls just
grow graffiti
[ __ ] everywhere is it really because
he's gay though because did they not
know for the last 20 years maybe they
didn't know
because because that's
because that's the reasoning that
they're using is we're kicking him out
why because he's gay duh is that illegal
that's gonna be illegal right yeah it's
probably like it's gay yeah it's gonna
be illegal yeah but but that's that's
like why would that be the reasoning
because even uh uh um like a christian
institution who's against you know gay
or whatever won't even admit that
because of discrimination lawsuits right
yeah they'll work around that word
do do like very uh upfront religious
institutions uh have the same
discrimination lawsuits when it comes to
things that like are conflicting with
their belief system
they do
thought that you know like japanese
people were the devil which is partly
true but then if they say you can't come
to this christian institution because we
just don't want your kind here then it
is still violating federal law i don't
know about that but some some stuff is
exempt like killing certain animals and
[ __ ] some of that is exempt by religion
so i wonder if some of the employee laws
might be different i don't know [ __ ] but
it's possible they can't they can't
discriminate based on uh
gender
they are they are you know like like
culture all these like those that's a
federal uh that would be a federal law
but i'm making some [ __ ] up like killing
a [ __ ] lion could be federally
illegal but some religions could be
exempt it's federally bad ass though you
know you mean like how natives can
locate when we can't yeah [ __ ] like that
some i think some religion like the even
with the covet [ __ ] like if you had
like a religious reason you don't have
to do [ __ ] sometimes well it's kind of
like no it's a federal law that every
business with a hundred employees has to
get vaccinated you don't need to put a
mask on the jesus on the cross
the baby jesus only
it also has to work with the nativity
scene yeah
i don't know i don't know the laws by
amish dudes are taxes exempt right
because they made a but that was like
they should rethink that i think they
should go you don't like that
[ __ ] have you ever been to like
amish country i kind of want to go do
you want to go in ohio there's a ton my
sister's man bro it's a trip
it's a trip where's like an amish
country pennsylvania yeah cleveland or
outside cleveland somewhere near
pennsylvania yeah
yeah so they are actually zooming over
this and i would too i guess like in the
speaker's message he did say something
about letting students expect a world
where you may be different and then i
think that was the trigger and they're
like how dare you make an example out of
this guy sending a message bro
awesomeness yeah which i guess like
according to the university it's just
not
allowed i don't know saying messages
heartwarming messages but it wasn't an
advocacy for gay rights whatsoever like
that's where they're sticking to that
but yeah they just i still just think
about say that andy dick in old school
he gives like a [ __ ] lesson to all
the ladies this dude just comes in
whipping out dildos starts teaching just
like has a bunch of banana hands out
bananas one by one is handing out
condoms and you fired me [ __ ] you
dude 40 years you get fired for that
that is wild imagine he's all pissed off
at his home he's like you didn't tell me
you were gay yeah i lost my job because
of you
[Laughter]
that's what he's mad about i went to
some uh christian institutions like like
that were like uh like christian private
schools right and then we did have like
gay
like students or whatever but they
weren't like like open about it maybe
but
no one really condemned it or anything
and there was never any homophobic
talk or anything like that but it might
have happened like with someone's
personal preferences but still there
wasn't like hate or any type of like you
i don't know like that weird like real
bullying what do you call it like when
you conversion camp [ __ ] like they never
had that stuff and we were in a strict
ass christianity too yeah we had there
were gay people in in that school but no
one [ __ ] with them but were they
out yeah they were i mean they were out
but they they also weren't [ __ ]
making campaign posters because they
were getting trouble for that [ __ ] yeah
but they were just like they're just gay
that's it they're not doing anything
some catholic schools uh if you get like
pregnant it'll kick you out to school
oh yeah [ __ ] like that because it's so
much against your religion
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you